hi everyone thank you for having me here
today and today we will be talking about
progressive rendering and how to make
your apps render sooner and first let me
introduce myself a little bit and maybe
you find some interesting facts from
here I worked as a dot net developer for
three years sorry for that I was blind
and then I fell in love with no jazz
because of its wonderful not blocking I
oh I really fell off that especially
from after the talk by Brian Dolph who's
a creator of node and then I worked as a
lead developer at flump which is like
really popular service in Russia kind of
like Yelp here and as you might guess I
work as a JavaScript developer already
and now I leave in Berlin and work for
Amazon building UI components for amazon
web services along with my great team
Michael colleagues and you can find me
online by these handle which is
pragmatic on Twitter github medium and
maybe something else give it a try and
we are going to talk about server-side
rendering and I think it's very
important to have service side rendering
today even if you have single page
applications mostly on on the Internet
we need sometimes we need server side
rendering 404 crawlers or maybe other
reasons and there is a good point how to
improve this server side rendering and
make it more film faster for our users
and for this we would talk about typical
server-side rendering today all
developers implement around the world
and why it's not that good for user
experience and how can we make it better
and let's start with a server-side
rendering in general like how typically
people implement server-side rendering
nowadays so usually use expert
is or connect or something like that and
just implement middleware for that and
it's basically a function that takes
HTTP requests HTTP response and
something like next call back if we
don't want to serve a page and just pass
the control to another middleware and in
this case we just parse some parameters
from URL then we just query some data
from the database or maybe a restful api
from somewhere doesn't matter then we
render template for this data and then
just end HTTP response with HTML so um
who has ever implemented rendering like
this raise your hands yeah and you might
be wondering what's wrong with that and
actually there are some things they that
are on so if you have dynamic HTML
document dynamic page we need to render
the whole page in suburbs memory in a
buffer and of course to generate this
page and to render template we need to
go to the database for data or maybe to
restful api just somewhere and
potentially it's a very slow operation
it might last for half a second maybe
more it depends and therefore it's kind
of risky because it depends on your load
on your network and the instant
infrastructure you had where a lot of
the facts of factors can influence um
that and let's imagine that we have up
to 10 requests for data and each of them
depends on a previous one in this
worst-case your users would not see
anything for five seconds and that's
really scary and let's ask our users
what do they think about that so some of
them I just said and they are crying
seeing how our appt renders
but they wait but some of them are very
angry and might be even want to find us
it kill us because we implemented this
up and some of our users are also
developers and might be they know that
progressive rendering exists and they
are just saying that our app is crap and
how can we fix this how can we make our
application render sooner despite these
reasons we have liked for requesting
data and maybe other air conditions we
have in our app instead of sending em
the whole HTML buffer at once like
previous code does we can use a simple
idea instead of trying to serve this
very heavy and slow page like lifting up
is the stadium we can just split this
page and small pieces in chunks and send
this HTML page as multiple chunks and
obviously it looks more powerful right
and easy so and this approach would be
progressive rendering this animation is
trying to explain how that works so on
the left side you have typical rendering
implementation which goes for data
building the page in memory and then
just gives the whole page service from
the server in browser and until this
moment nobody sees anything I mean our
users of course and on the right the app
uses progressive rendering which means
it has last time to first byte and you
have something as soon as your first
portion of data is radiant server and
this is really tricky because from the
performance point of view I mean from
amber's point of view it's kind of maybe
even slower but from the perception
point of view our users they see that
our app works for them and does
something for them and this perception
is much better than seeing nothing for
five seconds even though maybe it's
technically a little bit slower and
there was a talk at last jest Cairo in
Berlin where I unfortunately I can't
remember the name but it was a talk
about perception of performance and that
was a very similar idea that perception
says us that we need to do something as
soon as possible to show that our app
works for our user that we appreciate
that our user uses are up and this
exactly the point so you might be
wondering never heard of it never heard
of progressive rendering is it new or
like something train seeing which
invented recently actually now if we go
back in the history in 1997 HTTP 1.1 was
introduced as RFC and the most important
part in this for us is a Chunkin
encoding and basically what it says that
instead of serving the whole page the
whole buffer to a server you can split
it in several buffers and serve it
specifying length for each of them and
this is kind of a concept concept of
streaming if you are familiar with
Iraq's jazz observable or not jet
streams it's exactly the thing with
serving page in chunks and the first
mentioning of progressive rendering I
managed to find on the Internet is this
blog post by Jeff Atwood but let's call
the lost art of progressive HTML
rendering and it has two very
interesting points the first one is one
thing I dislike about a
dotnet is that it renders the entire web
page in memory before sending one single
bite of the page to the browser I am
totally agree with it and the second one
is what's even more galling is that HTML
was originally designed to render
progressively as content is received
what it means it means that even first
versions of the first browser in the
world Netscape they had support for
progressive rendering even in first
early beta releases that means that
browser goes through iterations
rendering the HTML in browser that means
if you have what partially piece of HTML
that come to you from the server you can
start parsing recognized resources like
screeds images styles and start load-in
them and in this case it works more
efficient because browser goes for for
resources in parallel while your whole
page is not ready yet so if you added
the previous code I showed you before
which looks like this which just ends
HTTP response with a vendor template we
can go further and using a little bit
more logic and maybe more complex
approach we can reach progressive
rendering without any additional tool we
just need to go for data just split our
data in small pieces and go for it in
steps like if we need data for a header
we go for just data for the header and
then render this team played for the
header and then serve the cutter and
this is perfectly done by right function
in response in HTTP response stream as
you can see here and then we go for
another blog another blog and do the
same operation for every blog on the
page
yeah I totally agree that this coat
looks really difficult and more
difficult even to split your every page
in such pieces and then serve it but at
the end we can use wonderful not GS
streams and the previous code would like
like this would look like this so it's
just we create our own stream with the
parameters we got from the URL and then
just pipe this dream through the HTTP
response stream and that's it but the
you might be wondering my response my
breed of all stream how to implement
that for those who is not familiar with
not jet streams API it's quite simple as
that you just extend some built-in class
in node you just implement read function
which allows you to push chunks of data
through the stream and that's of course
a synchronous and you can push whenever
you want and then when you stop pushing
and like the whole page is served you
just push now as a data this is how real
all streams work in not jazz without any
additional libraries just built in so
why progressive rendering is better so
the first thing I already mentioned is
less time to first byte for some
projects it's really an important
metrics used by teams by performance
engineers and other stuff in the company
and also it's very important for our
user experience because users should see
our app as soon as possible even though
it's not completely ready maybe but we
need to show something that we work for
our user
the second thing is browser works more
efficiently loading resources in
parallel and I will show you a
screenshot in a second how that works it
aligns with architecture based on
microservices very well because of the
main idea to split your data in small
pieces and serve them in blocks of your
page it's perfectly fine to have a set
of micro services which you can use
separately and every micro service is
just serves data of scope not going like
using other micro services you can use
them directly to build a page and even
though your API I mean restful api or
database is very very slow a user is
thinking that you're up in general is
really fast it's just technology this is
how it works how the perception of
performance works and this approach is
more scalable than buffering the whole
page why is that because if you add a
new block on your page like at the
bottom with some data if you have a
buffering approach your up would be
rendering slower but if you have
progress if rendering time to first by
it would be the same even though you add
something on the bottom or maybe on the
right of new page the first part of the
page would be delivered at the same time
which is very important and this is the
picture I promised to show this is a
screenshot of a real project built using
progressive rendering and for some
reasons the API of this project doesn't
serve data very fast and you can see
that the whole process of rendering
takes about three and a half seconds but
the first byte the first part of the
page was delivered in 327 milliseconds
which is pretty good like our users
didn't even notice that this app is very
slow and which is more important you can
see that
in parallel browser started involved in
other stuff like images scraped styles
and every browser has this limitation
how many HTTP requests that can do in
this at the same time and in this case
you can see that it's about four HTTP
requests in this tab of a browser
therefore like it blow loads resources
like all these three sources in parallel
then go goes for another three sources
and exactly so but however as all things
in real world it's not perfect and it
has problems that can stop you from
using it this how HTTP protocol works
before we have to specify HTTP status
code and always TP headers we need to
set before sending the first by
otherwise now JCP I just would ignore
all things you said after and even
doesn't throw an error or something we
just downside a cookie but you wouldn't
even notice that and you should keep in
mind that so that means that cookies
Redlegs not found statuses and stuff
like that you need to serve before
sending the first part of the page and
that means that you have to request the
main entity of your page first like if
you have online shop or something like
that you need to request the item of the
like of the shop on the market place
first and decide if the page status is
404 not found or maybe you need to set
some cookie but you would do it anyway
because you need meta tags and other
things in header which include this item
description and other stuff so in
practice it's not a huge deal
and user isn't able to interact with a
page till it's fully loaded I'm not
saying like the full interaction but if
you have JavaScript event handlers or
something related to JavaScript you
would probably need to wait for Adam
ready event and only then subscribe and
events and other things related to
JavaScript logic and that means that
your user would be able to click links
and to open those links on the page and
maybe submit forms all native HTML
experience works till the whole page is
loading and it's not ready yet but if
you have some JavaScript that attached
to an HTML and does something it does it
after dumb radiate end and I've found
some libraries that are still under
development but they make it part make
it possible to have this attachment to
Evans even before the dominant don't
read even I mean but it still up to you
to decide to use them or not and maybe
for someone it would be a decent
villages disadvantage as well but you
have to split your page the page data
into small pieces or microservices and
not I noticed that not everyone wants
that and not everyone likes that but to
have progress a friend when you need to
split your huge data request you have in
small pieces which would serve the page
like step by step chunk by chunk and
what about clients I'd rather you might
be wondering why I'm saying all the
things about server-side rendering and
say nothing about client signed that's
because actually it's very simple and
it's already used by many people in
single page applications like using
react library or
stuff like that and it's simple as just
split your data into small queries
render as soon as you've got its data
and try to make your interface not jumpy
using placeholders because it scans
constantly moving by a login and you
need to reserve the place for the
content like for instance Facebook does
Facebook actually uses progressive
rendering a client signed it and you can
see this like placeholders and your feet
on the right instead of like friends
suggestion or whatever is there and
before all data was loaded you can see
those clicks placeholders on the screen
and another question you might be
wondering is like is there a library of
framework which make it makes it
possible we don't want to read like a
lot of dogs and write this stream I
showed before and of course there are a
lot of ready solutions for that so I've
seen that some enthusiasts makes work on
the rag downstream which is the library
that makes it possible to render virtual
Dom on server like a stream in chunks
but I'm not sure about the lips is there
is library stable or is there any
problem with that I i would recommend to
check it out on your own and see if it
works also if you know the Zoolander
fashion online shop they use a project
called Taylor and what it basically does
just gathers HTML pieces from a set of
micro services every team develops like
a piece of HTML on the page and then
Taylor just gathers everything in one
piece and serves a page also there is a
click quite old team plant engine which
is does Jay
and it's forth by linkedin and what they
do is you can specify a function as a
property of data object when you render
your team played and when template
renders like this function it allows you
to go as synchronous and like request
any data and the stream would be post
till the moment your cut this data and
return is a call back also there is a
template engine called Marco or mark of
idiots it does pretty similar thing it
works as progressive rendering
everywhere on client signed and on
server also there's picking you template
engine called talisman I've just read
about this a month ago on medium and it
looks really promising and also if you
need not just a template engine but the
whole framework for building your art
based on this approach on progressive
rendering you might want to use Cadbury
jazz which is isomorphic framework based
on web components ideology using
progressive rendering let's summarize
the talk if you have many data requests
or a huge request you should plead in
small pieces it means you need
progressive rendering otherwise it would
be not that good user experience the
technology is basically very old and
perfectly supported by browsers since
the Netscape one point 0 therefore
everyone can use that it's not that hard
to implement and you can use not jet
streams for that and even if you don't
want to do that there are a lot of ready
solutions but you have to keep in mind
some disadvantages of that like setting
HTTP status code or HTTP headers cookies
redirects anything like that you have to
do that before the first chunk of data
is searched from the server
there are some existing solutions I
would really recommend them to check
them out and to experiment with them
maybe it's a good use case even not even
but especially for your project and your
company might be it would be better user
experience for your users or customers
but the point of the talk is don't make
your users wait just make your apps
render sooner and let them look like
this thank you so much